as you can see they're actually doing
you a huge favor here right this very
same question right repeat and say
question six if they just said give you
the function and then they just take a
graph it and it might get full marks on
it okay so have a look at the total look
like you got one two three four five six
seven eight eight marks really at all of
it is to get the wrap did you see that
so they're kind of being nice to you by
clicking this apart and I'm awarding box
for what might be usually pretty trivial
steps and that's why it becomes okay so
I think there's not much question about
the derivative it's fine and it's just
right or wrong when you get to this
we're not be doing the working in two
marks where do you think they go one for
the X and 1 for the Y okay now I did
hear the question what if someone gave
the decimal for log 4 now there's
actually for those of you who've done
your reading time and you're like oh I
have to sketch right actually it's
always makes sense to get a decimal
value okay the decimal would be a semi
can tell you right now okay because they
haven't specified find the exact value
and if they're looking for there's a
just like a bit off just like the cost
of integration in the Trina paper there
is one question and one question only
where they're testing your ability to
approximate so almost certainly your
question one no question 11 and they'll
say oh by the way this to two
significant figures or evaluate this to
four decimal places that's the only
place it gets assessed everywhere else
for instance like here if I put in the
decimal value it must be about one point
three something okay okay what you've
done is you've approximated but they're
not testing approximation so they don't
care it's fine okay
now should you do it in all your
questions
probably not okay but it would actually
get a set the most of the time unless it
was that one approximation question so
two months there
what was this what was about excellent
question
let's read the question shall we Part C
says the graph y equals f of X has one
maxint any point find the coordinates of
the maximum turning point and the
question says it's worth a few bucks
okay now just have a think about it with
me I won't make this a um my question
all that you said we could say - no
there's too many of them
what would suggest to you the answer
what would suggest to you in the
question that you don't have to show to
maximum I can see at least two clues
okay number one it says there is a
maximum turning point I actually think
that's a secondary thing because
sometimes I'll say there's a maximum but
all the information that's in the
question will give you the clue that
actually I do have to show it right
there's other tips that the question
gives you can anyone say it has okay it
just it just has one I still think you
could say that and I could wear it in
such a way that you'd be required to
test what's the HSC key word I know we
had to talk about HD key was very much
in this but it's there it's just fine
fine tell me what it is what might an
alternative if you were writing the
question and you wanted students to
prove it test the nature blah blah blah
you'd say sure you'd say sure right or
prove okay so number one I think fine is
the big clue the other clue is that it's
worth too much it's a little work to
actually show the nature of something
because you got to do it on both sides
or you're gonna do the second derivative
well
you'd expect that to be worth at least
three now of course you make an educated
guess what I would do in practice if I'm
ready to the exam and I would be
panicked right I look at my think to
that talk too much so I'm going to do
the short version and I'll leave some
space I'll come back to it later okay
the extension one you're probably going
to be pressed by the time we get to
seven right so maybe you might lose a
bit there but you do gain it you'll get
like an extra full box from the time you
spent here right it's a little bit like
when you get a question it might be
likes a rating mahjongg and potted
involves like you gotta prove two
triangles are similar right
it's Radian measure we're not really
testing triangle corners we're trying
tonight and it takes forever to prove
some triangles art because you got to do
this that the other and so on so what
you do is right now assuming triangles
are congruent if you have time to come
back you do it
if you don't you're not going to lose
very much anyway because congruence is
not the point of the question and do you
see what I mean by it you've got to get
into the head of markup okay so I've got
a few years up on you that's why this
comes a second nature to me but you guys
have a few months to get into that head
space and you can you really can it's
not as hard as it sounds so you didn't
need to show part three evaluate that's
one mark part four
it does say describe but you'll notice
all ever it needs this I've no sentence
nothing sometimes when they say describe
they want you to write stuff so how can
you tell that something like that would
be fine it's what mom the limit as it
approaches infinity is zero that's what
you need to say and you can also see
they're leading towards the graphic
pilot five again just a simple one okay
what does the graph look like
yes
okay I think that's about right
have a look it with me now there are two
marks here okay the reason why it's so
few marks for such a tricky graph is
because you have done so much work prior
that make sense so let's have a look
where would you put the marks
you've only got this food play with only
got two so we say shaped by shakes a bit
tricky because there's a few different
aspects of shape here that I think are
important okay if I could pin down to I
would put them down to curvature and
scale so I'm breaking up shape cuz she's
a bit boy into curvature and scale now
often you'll get away with a bit of a
shock you scale if it's not too accurate
you might get lucky and they'll just let
it slide tell me why you guys can see
the reason it's on the page in front of
you tell me why they're not gonna let
you get away with scale on a graph like
this where you weren't get away with
what you won't get away with it if it's
bad why well think about this we've
built up to this for a long time right
you had to find this you had to find
that you had to find this as well right
you know where everything is in relation
to each other now by the way this is log
4 which is log 2 squared which means
it's actually too long to so you've got
a lot of things to look out for number
one these two distances should be the
same - so you love - number two you've
found out where the stationary point was
it was an atom 8 and you found out where
the widest it was it was that - one
guess what this distance should be eight
times longer than this distance okay now
depending on how good everything is they
might let you sort of be they my
relaxant is some subjectivity - an
estimate
but you still know what you're looking
for okay so for instance if these things
are totally off right the shape is wonky
it doesn't approach the asymptotes the
scale is off and so on but you're like I
had returning point Mohammed intercepts
guess what you get a big fat zero right
because that was all free you'd already
gotten marks for that they're not gonna
pay you again so that's why they're
looking for these particular features
for a Chewbacca does it make sense
even though they didn't ask you to find
an inflection point it has to look like
an inflection point so even if it's not
there please make sure that the people
who your markings have a nice smooth
curvature there okay
no feathery graphs it should be one
smooth line okay so the asymptotes on
its own is not worth anything it's
whether the graph actually reflects it
or not so I'll train you examples stay
with me on this because this is me
trying to explain the way off and HSC
mark functions if I said one marque one
mark here I don't have half notes to
play with okay that means the curvature
has to meet a minimum what's a little
standard if it doesn't get above there
no matter how much other stuff it has it
won't get that mark so for instance
suppose I had an approach any asymptotes
and you look beautiful
okay but my stationary point in the
graph over here that looks straight at
different portions I don't meet the
baseline standard so you've got some
redeeming qualities it's not enough to
get you over the hump right you're gonna
think about it like high jump okay in
high jump
you can make a really great perch and
you can put your four can be great but
if you get the bar it's over you don't
meet the score right you don't
get that and improve on to your record
and so on so if you don't jump over the
minimum requirements they set the
asymptotes there but the shape doesn't
reflect it and so on it's going to get
that same interest scam any questions
yeah do you mean they're right here
no they're wrong this and then they've
carried it for how long is it what about
you want to so it should be here
shouldn't there but they are into
where's their intercept it's a lot
bigger girly I am confused what does it
look like I would suspect see the thing
is there are carried forward areas in
the narrow carry forward areas so that's
what which is self-contradictory that
want to get picked up right even worker
instance if it was log 8 so it's further
along you'd might never get away with
that it's already been paid